et pour décrypter la prise de parole du
ministre de la santé olivier verrons
nous sommes avec l'éditorialiste
alexis poulain bonsoir alexis vous
n'êtes pas seul avec nous pour revenir
sur ces annonces face à une épidémie
très actif dans le pays
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
bonsoir à vos côtés et richard di goy
président du collectif inter blog dont
soir merci messieurs d'être avec nous
donc on dirait que tu perds tes france
alors pour commencer je me tourne vers
le médecin généraliste bertrand legrand
désormais s est assumé par le
gouvernement est ce qu'on parle
clairement d'une seconde vague
je pense qu'on a un ministre de la santé
qui est réellement un confrère qui pense
qu'il a le coeur que d'un médecin qui a
envie de se battre contre la propagation
et je pense qu'on a un ministre de la
santé qui étaient empêchés par un
président de prendre les mesures qu'il
devrait prendre à l'heure actuelle en
tout cas ce que on est face à une
seconde vague aujourd'hui est ce que est
ce que c'est assumé par le gouvernement
est ce que c'est le cas on est
clairement dans une hausse de l'épidémie
savoir si c'est une deuxième une
première vague est un débat
d'épistémologie sts mes fans a enfin oui
on est dans une phase d'augmentation de
la maladie et on est dans la phase et
qui est encore réversible c'est ce qu'on
ressent tous et c'est pour ça que
normalement on devrait réagir dans une
limitation des liens sociaux
le plus rapidement possible afin
d'éviter un confinement partiel général
le cadre on va y revenir sur la
limitation des biens sociaux mais avant
eux rachid ni loi le président du
collectif un père bloc je le rappelle on
parle d'une très forte hausse des
contaminations
mais cette fois le ministre de la santé
le dit avec de meilleures conditions
d'hospitalisation par rapport au début
de la première vague est ce que vous
rejoignez cette affirmation théorie du
ministre et après à la pratique on sait
très bien sur le terrain que on est
toujours en manque notamment de
matériels d'équipements de protection
ça et le dit pas il a il l'a pas dit
dans son point presse
et on le regrette largement parce que
les équipes soignantes voudrais quand
même avoir un point sur les matériels
les masques tout ce matin dont on a
besoin en quantité et aujourd'hui on n'a
aucun recul on sait pas du tout
si les stocks ont été renouvelés ou pas
alors alexis poule a on vient d'entendre
le docteur bertrand legrand qui confirme
une hausse des contaminations sont
employés pour autant le mot sur le terme
seconde vague rachid digoin qui viennent
nous l'assuré les hôpitaux ne sont pas
plus près qu'avant finalement il manque
toujours du matériel
finalement c'est quoi ça un retour à la
case départ alexis c'est la même
situation qu'en mars dernier
oui on a l'impression que la première
vague n'a pas existé
rappelez-vous les discours le discours
martial du chef de l'état nous sommes en
guerre contre ce virus
tout ce qu'il avait fallu mettre en
place avant d'avoir enfin des masques et
du matériel pour les personnels
soignants de mettre en place les lits
dans les services de réanimation qui
n'était pas assez doté en lits et puis
on a fait cet été comme si le virus
avait disparu du territoire comme si
tout allait très bien ce n'était pas le
cas la pandémie continue est partout
ailleurs dans le monde y compris en
europe et on voit bien qu'il va falloir
vivre avec ce virus et pour longtemps
parce que le vaccin n'est pas pour
demain et que tout ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui ce sont les gestes barrières
les masques et un peu de vigilance des
uns et des autres plus quelques
bricolages de médecins qui pensent avoir
trouvé qu' une solution qui une autre
sans avoir malheureusement de d'études
qui a vers une solution par rapport à
une autre
donc aujourd'hui on est dans le
bricolage comme en mars on est dans
l'improvisation comme en mars et on est
hélas il faut le dire peut-être dans une
nouvelle stratégie de la part du
politique cette fois ci et non pas du
conseil scientifique qui garde sa ligne
qui de la part du politique serait de
faire limité de groupe sans le dire un
peu ce qu'avait voulu
la suède ou la grande-bretagne avec
boris johnson
mais sans utiliser le mot parce que ça
pourrait faire peur à certains c'est la
preuve dans les écoles puisque on a
assez maintenant que ce sont des foyers
de contamination mais il n'y a pas de
stratégie particulière par rapport aux
écoles
c'est la preuve dans la diminution de la
14ème finalement qui est maintenant de 6
jours et demi et la seule chose qui
reste eh bien c'est ces tests c'est est
massif qui sont mal organisés puisqu'il
faut attendre longtemps avant de les
faire et qui coûte cher parce que les
tests aujourd'hui sont remboursés à 100%
par la sécurité sociale
c'est plus de 73 euros qui sont
remboursés et si on calcule le nombre de
tests qui sont faits chaque semaine ça
va coûter à la fin de l'année à ce
rythme-là plus de 2 milliards sur le
budget de la sécurité sociale donc ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
prendre en compte ces tests là nous
coûte
il coûte moins cher en allemagne moins
cher en italie on a choisi nous
détestent coûteux remboursés à 100%
cette question là aussi est posée et
puis là le choix du politique est claire
aujourd'hui il y à un dilemme entre
l'économie qui doit repartir et cette
épidémie qui ne doit pas repartir mais
il faut ménager la chèvre et le chou et
c'est extrêmement complexe parce qu'on
ne va pas reconfirmer au national c'est
la pire des solutions donc il faut
maintenant trouver des solutions et ses
solutions et bien elles sont
malheureusement celle qu'on connaît et
qui ont été énumérées par olivier derand
aujourd'hui alors rachid digoit bertrand
legrand vient d'entendre alexis poulain
qui parle d'une idée d' immunité
collective qui serait mise en place par
le gouvernement des mesures de bricolage
également rachid dit loi qu'est ce que
ça vous évoque ce que ça va évoquer en
gros ce qu'on voit malheureusement c'est
qu'il ya eu une gestion catastrophique
du gouvernement dès le départ de la
pandémie ensuite on n'a pas du tout
consensus médical ça il faut il faut le
relever aussi malheureusement on voit
que les médecins il ya des médecins qui
font des tribunes d'autres qui l'on
fonde sur d'autres solutions et
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à
statuer sur quelque chose et c'est très
compliqué de s'y retrouver
donc aujourd'hui croire enfin que le
gouvernement souhaite une immunité
on a du mal à le croire puisque il a il
est quand même là pour protéger le
peuple un donc mais voilà on sait pas on
s'est passé assez tout pour nous
nous verrons nous dit pas tout peut-être
alors après avoir par la suite docteur
bertrand legrand qu'elle est quel est
votre regard alors sur ce bricolage dont
parlait alexis poulain concernant les
mesures
et puis sur cette idée d' immunité
collective est ce que finalement le
gouvernement parie un peu notamment avec
peu de mesure dans les classes dans les
écoles comme nous le disait alexis
poulain sur cette idée d' immunité
collective
l'idée de l'immunité collective c'est en
fait
l'idéologie de la reddition de la
capitulation et on a un goût vers un
gouvernement probablement menée par le
président qui a décidé de capituler par
rapport à l'accueil bataille la seule
bataille qui vaille le coup
qui sait la bataille de la contamination
on sait très bien que c'est en coupant
la contamination
qu'on arrête une épidémie ou qu'on la
limite choisir de l'immunité collective
c'est tout simplement capituler sauf que
d'un tout petit problème à ça c'est
qu'on est face à un coronavirus que le
coronavirus et très peu immunisant qu'on
le sait très bien depuis la première
vague qu'on le sait parce que la famille
des coronavirus et peu immunisant et que
la stratégie d' immunité de groupe ne
marche pas et que nous avons constaté
des réflexions déjà à travers le monde
certes faible mais je vous rappelle que
moi même dans mon cabinet j'ai vu des
trucs der contamination entre mars et
maintenant donc très un très clairement
la stratégie d'immunité du groupe ne
peut pas marcher il faudrait avoir 80 %
d'une classe d'âge en même temps avoir
une humilité qui dure entre trois et six
mois au mieux et pour avoir six mois il
faut passer en rien donc passé 80 % en
réa ça va être compliqué hein
en tout cas de forte recommandation
sociale également avancé par olivier
ferrand je vous propose d'écouter ont
réagi ensuite les chiffres sont
désormais sans appel la famille
les rassemblements amicaux sont des
lieux massif de contamination là aussi
des gestes barrières des réflexes de bon
sens ce sont les seules à même de nous
protéger
c'est pourquoi je vous le rappelle nous
sommes chacune et chacun d'entre nous
les acteurs clés de la lutte contre le
virus et les gestes barrière reste le
premier moyen de lutter contre
l'épidémie
en l'absence de vaccins et de
traitements efficaces
nous le répéterons jamais assez on la
vit cet été le risque était que le virus
passe des plus jeunes qui font moins de
formes graves mais qui peuvent en faire
vers les personnes moins jeunes et
vulnérables qui elles font plus de
formes graves
c'est ce que nous observons depuis
plusieurs semaines et la figure 2 montre
très clairement les courbes que vous
avez on voit que le virus circule très
activement donc chez les 15 45 ans mais
que chez les plus de 65 ans il circule
de plus en plus et cela depuis le début
du mois d'août ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
un impact réel et visible alexis poule à
cette idée de réduire ses contacts
sociaux c'est-à-dire finalement moins de
réunions de familles allaient moins voir
ses grands parents tout cas faire très
attention c'est indispensable selon vous
aujourd'hui
alors si on fait ça ça pose la question
des lieux de sociabilité tous les lieux
de sociabilité que faire des restaurants
que faire des open space passer toute
une journée en open space avec des
collègues que faire des écoles je le
disais que faire des universités
surchargé je trouve assez hypocrite de
vouloir culpabiliser les français dans
leur rassemblement privé sans pour
autant dire que les rassemblements
publics ou en extérieur ou qui sont de
la contingence du quotidien le travail
les études ne serait pas contaminants
c'est une c'est une hypocrisie totale
c'est peut-être pu mettre l'accent sur
ces rassemblements familiaux où on a
tendance à oublier les gestes barrières
parce qu'évidemment on se connaît en
famille on veut s'embrasser on veut se
rassembler ça fait du bien et on en a
besoin après après le confinement et
dans cette période d'incertitude que
nous vivons mais il faut rappeler aussi
que partout ailleurs les lieux de
contacts et de contamination ne sont pas
uniquement dans la sphère privée ça me
paraît être un message un peu dangereux
un peu particulier de dire que c'est
uniquement là qu'il faut faire des
efforts docteur bertrand legrand vous
disais au début de cette interview que
finalement il fallait éviter à tout prix
de multiplier les contacts qu'est ce que
vous répondez alexis poulain au vc 13
assez simple on a eu aujourd'hui des
études qui l'ont montré quand vous
n'avez pas de cas contactez identifier
la preuve la probabilité que vous allez
soyez quelqu'un qui mange très souvent
au restaurant et
et notez elle est la corrélation est
très très claires donc lui tout endroit
où il ya une promiscuité
on parle effectivement de contamination
en espace clos
les essais des regroupements dehors sont
très peu contaminants et les espaces
familiaux sont la majeure partie des
contaminations actuelle c'est évident
que dans un mariage personne ne porte le
masque j'ai une salle de mariage à 200 m
de chez moi je la vois du hot chez moi
je vois très bien qu'il ya 250 personnes
sans masque c'est le lieu propice la
question c'est d'eux qu'il terrain
depuis les contaminations
qu'est ce qu'on voit et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pas qu'est ce qu'on fera dans six
mois et dans trois mois combien de temps
il faudra pour que le politique se rende
compte de ce qui se passe sur le terrain
ce qui se passe sur le terrain
c'est une contamination des populations
à faibles doses qui diffuse dans toute
la société et chacun ne fait pas
attention ce qui va se passer c'est
l'histoire du même qui est venu me voir
et qu'il m'était jamais son masque il
est devenu quelques contacts et qui a dû
faire la liste de ses contacts et là il
s'est rendu compte qu'il avait mis son
entreprise en danger s'ils étaient
devenus positifs
forte heureusement pour lui il était
négatif mais penser à ça si vous devenez
positif le nombre de personnes que vous
allez contaminé sera important ou en
tout cas vous devrez les mettre en
septaine moi je préfère être modérée et
avoir une courte septaine pour peu de
monde que d'avoir un grand nombre de
personnes qui se retrouvent dans une
c'est peut-être parce qu'on n'a pas fait
attention parce qu'on a voulu absolument
préserver un lien social à un moment
donné tous les liens sociaux ne se
valent pas et certains doivent être mis
en pause maintenant parce que plus tard
ce sera trop tard
richard diois d'autres mesures ont été
évoquées notamment le port du masque
pour les personnels en crèche des
annonces aussi concernant les tests
quel est votre regard sur toutes ces
annonces qui ont été faites ce soir est
ce qu'elles vont effectivement empêché
un afflux massif vers les hôpitaux
non je pense pas du tout pas du tout
après en ce qui concerne et est on voit
aujourd'hui que monsieur verront se
félicite du million un million deux cent
mille tests qui seront effectués mais
sur le terrain c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué on sait très bien on a des
témoignages qui remontent du terrain
comme quoi
ballet se faire tester il ya souvent une
attente violents jusqu'à une semelle
trouve un laboratoire c'est très
compliqué voilà il ya la théorie comme
gêné au début et la pratique donc c'est
vrai qu'au niveau des tests ça reste
très compliqué de se faire tester après
il ya ce qui s'enchaînent c'est aussi
des foyers les arrêts maladie forcément
puisque si on est suspect on doit
s'arrêter
les gens peut être aussi hésité au
niveau de leur travail à s'arrêter
france et c'est très compliqué la
situation est très compliquée
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne tous ça
alexis poulain vous avez souvent sur
cette antenne soulevé la cacophonie
autour de ces fameux tests alors des
nouvelles mesures
les kinés on a appris aussi vont pouvoir
tester il y a également une vingtaine de
nouveaux de centres de tests qui vont
être mises en place
c'est suffisant pour vous est ce que
finalement le gouvernement a fait un
petit peu un mea culpa sur la question
des tests ce soir et a pris les bonnes
mesures
oui oui j'aimerais l'a dit qu'il y avait
eu un peu des couacs dans la façon dont
les tests avaient été mis en place
parce que finalement le temps d'attentes
fait que le test devient inutile donc il
a fallu organiser mais ça fait partie de
la planification qui aurait dû être là
bien en amont puis ce qu'on avait vécu
la première vague que qu'on avait le
problème d'approvisionnement sur les
produits réactifs
on avait le problème et qui a été
soulevée par tous les médecins de ville
en disant mais pourquoi on n'a pas plus
de testeurs et pas uniquement les labos
qui sont surchargés et qui ne peuvent
pas le faire des tests sous tente en
plein air aura testé massivement ce que
faisait le doctorat ou de la marseille
donc donc pourquoi ne pas partager les
bonnes pratiques et dire on va
multiplier les tests et faire en sorte
que tout le monde puisse être testé en
temps et en heure pour que les résultats
et bien soit juste et qu'on sache où
nous en sommes dans la courbe donc
heureusement que l'on reprend mais que
de temps perdu
on savait que la rentrée arrive et on
savait que le virus était toujours en
circulation et le gouvernement n'avait
rien préparé
et c'est quand arrivent les courbes que
ça devient visible qu'on commence à en
parler que les médecins s'inquiètent et
alerte à nouveau que le conseil
scientifique alerte à nouveau que le
politique prend conscience de son
impréparation et qu'il répare
les manques mais on aurait pu gagner des
semaines au mois d'août en préparant
justement cette filière de test et en
s'assurant que les tests seraient prêts
plutôt que d'avoir cette communication 8
200 ce qui fait beaucoup d'annonce et
très peu de très peu de
de mise en place d'ailleurs bertrand
legrand une question que beaucoup se
posent on lisait tout à l'heure les
kinés viennent à la rescousse un des
labos pourquoi les médecins généralistes
peuvent pas testé aujourd'hui
alors pour répondre à cette question moi
je teste dans mon cabinet depuis le mois
d'avril et contre l'avis de la rs à
l'époque le meilleur moyen d'avoir un
test rapide c'est que le médecin
généraliste le fasse parce qu il le fait
au moment où il voit la personne c'est à
dire qu'on est capable de faire le tri
en amont ont donc on évite les tests
inutiles qui sont à plus de cinq jours
qui je vous rappelle le texte n'est pas
un test diagnostique ça n'est même pas à
la limite un test de dépistage c'est un
test pour en vue de limiter la
contamination donc rendre un test au
delà de cinq jours à partir du moment où
les sang et or ont commencé ça veut dire
qu'on n'aura aucun impact sur la
génération numéro 3 et je vous rappelle
que nous ne nous battons pas nous ne
faisons pas un test pour le patient on
le fait même pas pour sa femme et ses
enfants ses parents
on le fait pour les contacts de sa femme
ses enfants et ses parents là que se
joue la bataille non pas sur la
génération de non pas sur la génération
mais sur la génération iii donc vraiment
il faut garder son calme sur les tests
c'est une stratégie qui nécessitent
d'être évalués on a besoin en fonction
des quantités des tests de choisir c'est
ce que je fais tous les jours qui je
vais tester
est-ce que je teste celui qui a dit
contact ou est ce que je le teste celui
qui a sans contact bien évidemment je te
reste celui qui a sans contact et je ne
prends évidemment pas en compte le fait
que la personne soit à risque ou pas un
risque puisque de toute façon je vais la
traiter en fonction des symptômes donc
le test doit être réservé à la
limitation des contacts qui pourraient
être isolées et c'est uniquement ça qui
nous intéresse
rachid un iguane c'est le personnel
soignant dans les hôpitaux prioritaires
1 pourrait être testé ça fonctionne bien
aujourd'hui il ya plus de problème à ce
niveau là bah écoutez nous on était sur
toute la période
cosider jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc depuis
mars aujourd'hui on a été testé une
seule fois et d'ailleurs il ya eu de
gros doutes puisque on a eu une
sérologie on n'a pas eu de pcr c'était
ce protocole et de sérologie et les
personnes qui avaient été testées
positives à la pcr sont revenus négatifs
la sérologie donc il ya le gros doute de
ce côté là sur sur la fiabilité des
tests
on en parlait tout à l'heure donc après
voilà nous ça on ne sait pas quand on
parle de test les soignants ya pas de
politique de tester les soignants
puisqu'on est on est les premiers
exposés aussi donc aujourd'hui ben on ne
sait pas alors des nouveaux tests
antigénique un cx vont être fournies en
octobre
ce trop tard ou pas bertrand legrand je
me permets de faire de répondre à mon
combat mon collègue hui très clairement
l'état n'a pas à assumer sa
responsabilité en ne faisant aucune pcr
aux soignants et donc en rendant cette
maladie nosocomiale
aujourd'hui si vous avez un test qui est
positif vous ne pouvez pas savoir si
c'est des restes de virus ou si vous
êtes actuellement contagieux je suis
désolé je vais dire quelque chose de pas
très agréable mais un aide-soignant une
infirmiers ça se remplace un médecin
on peut se poser la question mais
franchement aujourd'hui laissée au
travail du personnel soignant entre
guillemets ratera remplaçable dans la
mesure où on pas encore en place et des
gens fait à purement criminel en termes
de propagation de la maladie dans des
zones où elle est la parfaite
parfaitement dangereuse donc ça très
clairement c'est inadmissible et ça
serait dès lors a forcément devant les
tribunaux à distance de l'épidémie c'est
évident pour ce qui est des tests
antigénique with nous simplifierait les
choses notamment en accélérant les
personnes qui sont de l'ordre du
dépistage c'est à dire tous ceux
contesterait entre guillemets à
l'aveuglent pour trouver des assemblées
thématiques qui ne serait pas identifiée
comme des cas contacts donc ça vit ça
peut servir ça va nous fera gagner du
temps et ça diminuera le nombre de tests
pcr et enfin sur le coup du test moi je
préfère dépenser deux milliards en test
que de dépenser 700 milliards en
confinement
je suis pas prêt à payer 700 milliards
sur mes impôts j'espère que je serai pas
le seul à le payer
peut-être le mot de la fin alexis
poulain il y à des civils qui ont déposé
plainte contre des membres du
gouvernement pour mise en danger lors de
la crise du coc vie 19 y aura d'autres
cas selon vous quel est votre regard sur
ces plaintes déposées oui c'est
important parce que on est dans une
démocratie où finalement les
contre-pouvoirs sont assez défaillant et
la justice
cette partie donc pour faire la lumière
sur cette affaire on a bien sûr les
commissions d enquête parlementaire qui
sont en train d'auditionner plusieurs
personnes mais on va avoir besoin aussi
du regard de la justice pour bien faire
le jour sur la chaîne de responsabilités
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce convoi de la
part des politiques des élus et du
gouvernement c'est d'essayer de diluer
la responsabilité de se défausser pour
être responsable mais pas coupable comme
on l'a connu dans d'autres grands
scandales sanitaires
donc cette fois ci les citoyens ont pris
de l'avancé et ont décidé de saisir la
justice et les plaintes sont déposées
on peut espérer que il y aura des
enquêtes du côté de la justice et qu'on
saura ce qu'il s'est vraiment passé si
on a menti sur les masques si on a menti
sur la façon dont on a pris en charge ce
virus si eu des graves défaillances dans
la chaîne de commandement
ça me paraît être la moindre des choses
les français méritent la vérité
merci beaucoup à l'équipe ou là vous
restez avec nous on vous retrouve dans
la deuxième demi heure de l'émission
merci à vous bertrand legrand d'avoir
participé à d'autres émissions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste
un grand merci à vous rachis de digoin
président du collectif interlock